I always wondered how Raisa managed to
keep himself entertained being stuck on
greed island with so few players ever
actually embarking into the game much
less actually reaching him but then one
day it all made sense when I found this
picture that cleared everything up
because apparently Raisa is a subscriber
of the new world review which grants him
regular hunt on two content straight
into his YouTube feed hello and welcome
to the new world reveal source for
everything anime and manga and it's
hunter hunter time again as we continue
our in-depth exploration into the world
of nen this time focusing on the
discipline of omission now as always if
you are new to the concept if nano just
need a basic refresher then this video
is available which is something of a 101
course on the earth for a lot form as
well as using it as assumed knowledge in
regards to this video but onwards to the
wonderful world of a mission and this
discipline consists of the fairly basic
mechanic of being able to separate one's
aura from their body and that might
sound a bit odd at first because that
technical definition would at face value
appeared to be part of other affinities
as well such as conjuration and
transmutation which are both capable of
technically separating ore from the
bodies of the user however a key
difference is that conjuration and
transmutation go on to transform aura
into an object or substance meanwhile
emission is all about raw ore output
which can be surprisingly difficult
because once aura naturally wants to
remain within its vessel and the process
of separating it actually goes on to
decrease its potency which only gets
worse and worse depending on how far the
ore is from the body and for an example
of this we can look at mr. gone because
he actually uses a form of pure emission
as part of his drunken series
specifically with the attack known as
paper and this basically sees gone
gather his aura in a similar manner to
that of his trademark Rock technique
which is a form of enhancement except
that with paper gone launches his aura
directly and an enemy as a form of
projectile the sort of glorified hunter
hunter a Kamehameha and it's quite a
powerful albeit straightforward
technique because gone is an absurdly
talented child thing however due to the
fact that it is a use of pure emission
despite putting the same quantity of
aura into the attack as he does with
rock the result of paper contains only a
quarter of the raw power and a lot of
that is attributable to gone not being a
natural emitter but compounding that is
also the general fact of reduction in
aura potency post-separation even if you
are a natural emitter so with that in
mind a sort of tip-top emitter is an
individual who is capable of separating
their ore
with minimal loss of power as well as
over great distances and no it's not
always about destructive power as we
will thoroughly explore and there is a
ton you can do with the mission that
goes far beyond a simple energy blast in
fact in my opinion the best uses of a
mission that we've seen in the series go
far beyond that basic idea before we hop
into things though according to his
ogres personality framework an emitter
tends to be impatient not particularly
detailed oriented and quick to act in a
volatile way they're also quite
impulsive although they allegedly tend
to calm down much easier from their
volatile actions as opposed to say
enhancers and this is another mixed bag
from the University of ahsoka I think
certain aspects can apply to certain
emitters but there's really only a
couple that I can think of that fit this
bill perfectly to start the examination
off proper though we kind of do have to
delve into Raisa
who was probably the most memorable
emitter in the series whose aura ball
actually mimics the idea of Gaughan's
paper projector however in the case of
Razer what we see happens to be this
idea perfected Razer can generate
exceptional quantities of aura condensed
into a much smaller package that deals
damage several orders of magnitude
higher than gone could ever dream and
not only that but Razer can emit his
orany instantly and have it travel much
further from his body thanks to his
sporting prowess and he also has
superior control of targeting and this
attack is the quintessential pinnacle of
pure mission but Raisa himself makes far
more complex use of this affinity as he
is a game master of greed Island and
directly responsible for all of the
emissive needs of the card game now very
notably this likely does not include
generating the cards themselves which is
more in line with conjuration and I'm
sure that someone else handles that now
whether he would be responsible for the
miss of mechanics found primarily in
spell cards like a company for example
which releases aura that is then used to
teleport players to a location of their
choosing and so with that in mind raise
it displays both the most simple and yet
the most complex uses of a mission in
one pretty stacked gym teacher wrapped
package and I really don't think that
anybody else in the series has even come
close to demonstrating a higher degree
of mastery over mission than Razer
however we have certainly seen more
diverse usage and with that I would like
to now immediately turn to melody
another natural emitter with a very very
cool ability known as enchanting music
in which she can relieve fatigue and in
some cases even cure the illnesses of
those listening to her music and this is
achieved by melody emitting her aura
whilst playing her flute which then
reaches and activate
anybody caught within a certain radius
and it can also cause listeners to
hallucinate as well depending on how
much of her heart melody puts into the
performance so the technicalities of the
hearts who are unclear but I would
hypothesize that the music played
possibly specifically through her flute
is obviously a condition placed on
emitting her or in this matter as is
Melody's own passion was playing which
is important because without that second
condition this would be quite supremely
powerful especially because it also
seems to take effect if her music is
broadcast but in the end it's just a
really fascinating take on pure mission
very much the opposite of destructive
energy blasts and also an intriguing use
on adding conditions to roar emission
but for some more let's say very basic
examples we can now look at both
Franklin Bordeaux of the Phantom troupe
as well as basta of the chimera and true
and both of these emitters have very
similar abilities which sees them
emitting their aura into much smaller
but still very potent ways that go on to
mimic gunfire and thus transform both of
them into incredibly deadly weapons now
in Franklin's case specifically he chose
to plunk an extra condition on his
hatsue which is that he voluntarily cut
off his fingertips and made it so that
he could only fire after removing them
which has he quite correctly thought
would lead to an increase in power of
the overall ability due to the
limitation so for what is effectively an
incredibly basic use of a mission
Franklin has very much maximized his own
personal output and is a master of Nan
in his own right as are all members of
the Phantom troupe really whilst err on
the other hand he's well he's bluster
however I refuse to go any further
without recognizing our lost protagonist
Lee Oreo who after an awfully awfully
long time we discovered is a natural
emitter with quite a funky Honsou being
remote Bunch
whereby la orilla makes a physical punch
to no impact and then emits his aura to
replicate the punch at a target of his
choosing which emerges from an emitted
wormhole style thing
now it's kind of a vaguely defined
ability and we're mostly left to deduce
how it works on our own and as a result
there is sometimes quite a bit of
confusion surrounding it with many
believing that ley Oreo opens a nan
wormhole and then punches through to hit
a target whereas in reality what he does
is meet the condition of a physical
punch assumedly infused with aura and
then that aura travels to its
destination and manifests itself as a
fist and arm that strike a target with
the same physical force that ley oreo
initially put into his own punch and
fascinatingly enough this is one of the
first examples in the series that we
have
to being copied because Jing freaks
after being hit by this immediately
understood the technical implementation
of it and he would go on to use it in
his favor to defeat some assailants the
parastone had hired to try and make Jing
use his quote-unquote true nan abilities
and very notably this example of copying
power is not Jing Sun Tzu this man is
just so talented that he is able to copy
very basic usage of nan and he also even
expanded upon remote punch by sending
multiple limited fists which is a nice
escalation that the area would assumedly
be capable of if he decided to invoke it
and if he had the oil reserves to do sir
once again though it is a very nice take
on pure emission especially for those
who are more physically inclined because
you would think that brawlers would be
quite incompatible with the mission due
to the fact that it is most effectively
used at long range but no a proficient
wielder can just brawl from a very long
distance which is actually kind of
terrifying I mean just imagine if
someone like GU virgeen had a hot su
like remote punch the world would be
doomed and a further twist on punchy
punching can be found in the character
of Lynch fo boku who is confirmed to be
a natural emitter and her ability body
and soul has Lynch Oscar target a
question and then punched them
repeatedly with each punch managing to
deliver an answer to her inquiry and I
would strongly hesitate to call this
pure omission because that does seem to
be elements of manipulation spiced in
and the results of this I guess can be
referred to as some sort of truth punch
but omission is still there because it
does require Lynch to project her aura
either into or onto the target in
question continuing on though we come to
another beloved character in the form of
pockle who gives us seemingly very basic
example of a mission which is him
emitting aura to use as an arrow for
hunting and/or combat this is a lot
trickier than it seems though because
Paco isn't just using rora mission he's
also calling upon transmutation with the
hours as well which you can see very
clearly in the example of the red arrow
which upon contact with the target will
burst into flames so POC will
effectively emits his aura in the shape
of an arrow but also transmutes it into
the properties of fire which is very
intriguing actually the fact that he can
transmute his aura after it has left his
body and so he is probably a much better
nen user than he would generally receive
credit for especially because
transmutation is far from the natural
ally of a mission and I mean look it's
not the worst possible discipline that
would be conjuration but still the fact
that pockle is making effective use of
an affinity to spots removed from his
own is very noteworthy with this in mind
though the natural ally of an emitter is
obviously enhanced
manipulation especially manipulation
actually because that opens up a whole
sub-genre of nen which is an in beasts
so for example shot mono journey off new
city arc utilizes brilliant combination
in his eleven black children hunter
which sees him omitting his aura into
the shape of these bizarre doll soldiers
and then manipulating them to act as a
small personal army they are very
limited to simple commands but this is
how natural emitters go about creating
and beasts because the other standard
method would be to use conjuration but
that of course is not really an option
for emitters nor is it required because
they can emit some pretty fantastic
things like knuckle for example Kawara
is a hunter that makes use of two nan
beasts being a PR and IRS both of which
are emitted existences and then
manipulated to perform their own
purposes what is interesting though is
that emission is generally considered a
release of raw aura however in many many
cases of these emitted nen beasts they
are clearly given form beyond that of
aura but an example of an aura generated
nan beast would be something like Zeno
zoldak submitted dragon that thing is
clearly just pure aura whilst a PRI RS
xi like children and many many other
abilities including raises 14 Devils at
least have the illusion of being
something solid and quite probably the
grand champion of this would have cost
be the 100 type guanyin bodhisattva
wielded by isaac natural although i
should say that there is potential that
this nin beast is conjured just because
well it's natural we're talking about
although as a natural enhancer emission
would be much much easier for the former
chairman to use however there is a
definite emissive mechanika play in
regards to zero hand which is probably
the most destructive force of raw or
emission that we've seen in series which
focuses every last drop of Metro's
extensive oil reserves and fires it in a
condensed blast of doom which I
guarantee would have obliterated anybody
who didn't happen to be a chimera ant
king at the time anybody else sir wolf
you're in trouble
but yeah I think that gives us a pretty
good overview of a mission I will once
again encourage all of you not to just
think of it as like a Qiblah style
ability because even pure mission holds
so much more potential than that as we
have seen with melody lee oreo and the
crazy card mechanics of razer however I
will say that I feel like through my
anecdotal experiences omission is one of
the more underrated disciplines which is
a bit of a shame because it's actually
stupidly versatile and has a great great
Ally with manipulation allowing the easy
crafting of
and beasts and not only that but an
emitter can also dip into enhancement
for the own physical protection if
necessary most also a meeting there or
elsewhere so it provides very capable
and balanced offensive and defensive
options so yeah good emitters of the
hunt underworld we salute you and you're
emitting emit eveness but what do you
guys think please do leave your thoughts
in the comments below or even join mine
discord server and if you came for some
more hunt onto content and I know you
are then please do go and check out some
of my other videos or even subscribe to
the channel for regular hunt on to glory
to live it straight until YouTube feed
but for now this has been the new world
review and I'll see you next time